I can't imagine riding a [__] bull
that was one of one times on Fear Factor
where I told the producers don't do it
don't do it I got there and they had
these one of the girls was like 98 PBS
this tiny little lady and they had her
ride in this ball go dude don't don't do
this to these people and the [__] the
stunt men are some of the hardest dudes
you will ever meet those dudes are not
worried about Broken Bones they break
them all the time they're not worried
about [__] so they're not worried about
themselves getting injured they take
precautions you know they they're
professional but they're definitely not
worried about these [__] getting
injured either they don't want them to
get injured but they'll put them in
danger yeah and I was like these are
[__] bulls and the this stun guy he
was hilarious he always had a dip in his
mouth and he was on set so often that he
stopped spitting his dip because he
couldn't like carry around a cup so he
just started swallowing it so he
swallows his dip what kind of a man is
just there swallowing dip for
decades that kind of dude yeah and so he
was like don't worry boo they're stunt
Bulls I go there're stunt Bulls I go
does that bull know he's a stunt bull I
bet he thinks he's a [__] bull I bet
he has no idea what a stunt bull is yeah
and the stunt bull is like a less
aggressive for sure yeah that thing was
aggressive as [__] I call them I call
like the one I have he would be like my
bucket list bull because like if
somebody just wanted to get on a bull
for the hell of it like I would put him
on this one black bull we call him trunk
he just jumps and kicks around there and
he's a little he's kind of predictable
and he's not mean at the end of it and
then we've got some other bulls that you
know will get it on in the gate and then
be mean and might try to kill you but I
imagine I I vaguely remember the show
and what I remember about it it would be
like something probably a a notch or two
above trunk like my bucket list type
bull ride like if you were to get on a
bull I would put you on trunk yeah it's
not going to
happen I'm so not interested in that
they don't want me on there I don't want
to be on there we got a relationship
that way it's we got a good agreement
and and normally I try to talk people
out of it good like I got my whole
program like is revolves around like
interns coming in like my Netflix show
was those like my my my interns learning
how to Rodeo and they uh and so I've got
guys coming in that want to ride Bulls
want to ride Bronx and I'll tell them
like all the thing like listen number
one you could die or worse you know you
could die from the neck down and not the
neck up you know right and I'll just be
real with them I'll have three or four
of those conversations and if they still
want to do it well then I'll teach them
you know because there's there are some
precautions you can take to minimize
risk but there's always risk yeah you
get you might get kicked yep stepped on
you might get stomped you get stomped by
a bull like good
Lord have you been stomped oh yeah what
does that feel like
uh I've broke I've broke a lot of Bones
like this I broke my sternum like you
know getting kick you know stepped on in
the chest that that one's pretty bad but
a lot of the worst ones would be like
concussions that's the those are the
ones that'll stick with you you know
those bones will heal but the
concussions will kind of you know that
CTE that's something that's not measured
in Rodeo right you know what I mean
right you get some guys that all of a
sudden start getting knocked out just
they can think about getting jerked down
and it might knock them out yeah that
gets sketchy right yeah when the chin
goes yeah yeah I mean it's just like
Fighters you get knocked out too many
times and you get knocked out really
easily it's very spooky to see when I
see it in Fighters it makes me very
concerned like sometimes you got a guy
who's just maybe had just too many
fights and they used to be real durable
and then you see him get dinged once and
you see like instantly the legs go and
you're like oh my God he barely got
touched yep and he got
rocked yeah there's just I'm sure with
Fighters too there's just this once that
sport grabs a hold of your soul it's so
hard to let it go and it's the most
exciting moments of your life is winning
and and and competing and that that high
is so high that regular life seems like
a dull gray and I think it's very hard
for them and it's also hard for them
because their identity gets wrapped up
in being a fighter a lot of my friends
that have retired they real they really
struggle like trying to figure out who
they are afterwards and then they
entertain one more fight and then it's
like but they don't really want to fight
they just want something that makes them
excited again yes sir and there's kind
of a I think the winning and going down
the road is part of it and then you you
have those certain
individuals that and I think I mean you
know a lot of them in that world I I
feel like cowboy is definitely one of
them Cerrone but like in Rodeo when
there's somebody that is in love with
the actual fight yeah you know like I
think a lot of people and these guys get
weeded out they don't have that long of
a career in Rodeo I'm sure fighting is
the same that like they like to have
fought they like to have rid and Bulls
but then you get those guys who like
cameras are off nobody's there and they
don't like they want to get on a bron
like they love the thrill of that fight
not your head the gate opens and it's
it's you and it's so pure so pure and
I'm sure like a fighter that is just
they're just hungry for it yeah the
actual between the bells yeah that's
what's scary may maybe all of them that
on your level they're all like that I
think they would have to be I guess to a
degree once they get to the highest
level I mean that that is who they are
you know like Donald I mean he's a pure
fighter but Donald is also very he has a
lot of interests I'm not worried about
Donald transitioning because he's he I
think he has a legit possibility to be a
movie star I think he could do it if any
of those guys could do I mean movies are
always looking for like a a real hardl
looking Cowboy [__] and Donald's
that guy yeah I mean he's perfect for
movies I I could see him like Randy
cotur has turned it into a career in
films you know with the Expendables
movies and all kinds of other [__] I I
could see Donald doing that easy 100%
yeah Chuck did it a little MH uh yeah
we're working on a comedy I don't know
if you saw his short that he did at his
Ranch the other day on Halloween he put
out like a 10minute like like a little
mini movie Donald did yeah it it's it's
really cool it was very well put
together and uh we're working on he and
I are doing like a comedy where nice
yeah so I got a guy working for me
that's writing it right now beautiful so
it'll be fun I love Donald he's a he's a
wild boy yeah he wants you to come out
to his uh kids camp seems to what is
that what is his kids camp uh it's it's
in the summer in June he does like he
just has kids come out and and they just
learn to be like miniature Cowboy cerris
like they they we shoot bows guns um
they roll every day and they just
there's sessions campfire sessions at
night that's like awesome 50 60 kid
that's his that's probably the thing
he's most passionate about now that he's
done fighting is that's beautiful he
talks about it all the time he's got a
good heart yeah he really does yeah it's
a good man but he told a story on this
podcast about getting trapped in a cave
while cave diving with this dude and the
dude panicked and the cave got filled up
with mud you couldn't see anything one
of the even though he was right there
and I knew he survived like it was one
of the most [__] terrifying stories
I've ever heard in my life cuz he was
running out of air and he couldn't
figure out how to get out of the cave
because it was all filled with silt so
he's like searching around for the
opening to try to figure out how to get
out yeah that was an intense story [__]
thinking about his family thinking about
his kids and his wife and and never see
them again he's going to die in this
cave like [__] but he's got that never
quit attitude yeah and also like don't
go cave dive with people who Panic yeah
you know just people who Panic are
dangerous don't do anything with people
that Panic don't do anything like you
have to experience Panic many times in
your life and figure out how to manage
that before you start [__] around in
caves yeah that should not be the first
time you really Panic I'm nervous if a
situation went down that
I I'm not saying I'd be some badass I'm
just saying like I might be too
desensitized having been around Rodeo
like yeah an emergency situation would
be like we'd be 8 nine 10 seconds into
it before I'm like oh man we need to do
something right just cuz like seeing
guys get crashed in the arena and and
like having to help them you know like
situations like that right I don't know
but I'm sure
Fighters are the same way but they
definitely get desensitized to people
getting hurt y for sure you know one
time uh my wife uh she had like a one of
those uh SUVs with a hatchback thing and
she was taking something out of the back
and the the corner of the door was above
her head and she didn't know and she
stood up and slammed it the corner of it
right into the top of her head and Blood
starts trickling down her face she was
freaking out and I looked at her I'm
like it's like that big it's like a
little cut we could super glue it I was
like it's nothing yeah I was like to me
it was like if was that was my head I
would be like oh it's just a little cut
it's no big deal but you're like
BL and I'm like oh my God I'm so it's a
person I love more than anyone and I'm
so desensitized to like a little cut
yeah I'm like this is nothing yeah this
is like a barely an injury I'm so used
to seeing people just bust it open their
[__] eyelids hanging off their face
and like don't stop the fight Let Them
Fight You know you're so used to seeing
guys that that probably have a broken
hand because they haven't thrown it in
two rounds he's so used to seeing guys
get [__] I've seen so many guys I've
seen like four guys have their legs
snapped from checking kicks now you see
you see so many injuries yeah you get so
desensitized seeing people just getting
[__] knocked into another dimension
with a head kick it's so normal how
rodeoed with a guy um we went together
for years Ross shared he was a marine so
he came back from Iraq and started
riding bear back horses and he
got he got uh jerked down into like a
pipe vence and uh just like crushed his
face like had to like surgery and like
and he just never knocked out just like
stood up and he's this little stocky you
know Marine you know like door to door
marine and he just like walks out he's
like I'm going to go down here to the
hospital just blood everywhere broken
eye socket broken everything and uh you
know we helped him
and uh but it made me think you know
like I feel like I've seen quite a bit
of injuries with the rodeo Arena but I
can't imagine guys like Ross or even Tim
right who have done MMA and been to
Afghanistan yeah that's a different
level of seeing people get [__] up
yeah watch somebody come out without an
arm not just an arm broken well you know
tulsy gabard she has that white streak
in her hair that that came when she was
deployed when she was working on these
medical units dang yeah that's where she
got that just from the horrors of seeing
all these people shot up blown up trying
save their lives trying to put them back
together again yeah dang yeah yeah
that's something you can't unsee yeah
yeah there's I mean and there's so many
people in this world that have
experienced
nothing right and just floating around
yeah not not having any experience with
any kind of chaos yeah a little bit of
pain here and there is uh I don't know
just to show you what the good times
mean it gives you some perspective
persec for sure and seeing how
vulnerable the human body is you know
we're vulnerable as [__] yep whether we
like to think of it or not think of
yourself as a badass you're still made
out of basically a [__] meat water
balloon right you know it's it'll it'll
it'll make it is this water open yeah
yeah let's grab that it'll make a guy
come to Jesus on the back of the shoots
that's for sure oh yeah especially
coming back from an injury oh I would
imagine cuz then you got to get back on
the horse right literally yep yeah how
did you start rodeoing when how old were
you I mean I was born into it my dad
was I was kind of I was on the rough
roughy end of the Arena so like if you
go to a rodeo Arena there'll be timed
event side and a rough stock side the
timed event is like
uh Team
Roping uh calf roping barrel racing and
then the rough stock end is the bucking
horses bucking bulls bull fighters
pickup men there's five things you can
do down there um beback sadle Bron bull
riding and then the pickup man and the
bull fighters so there's five jobs you
do on that rough stock end and my dad
did all those and so like I grew up like
a ruffy so to speak and fell in love
with all of it and uh you know it's kind
of two stories bull Ren I'm the greatest
of all time and the most humble you know
I'm sick and tired of YouTube pulling
down all my bull rods you know it just
gets old do they pull your bull down so
I'm just so violent just so violent but
Bron riding has been like the thing that
I've chased and like that's what that's
one of the last things my dad did and
Bron riding it's similar to bull riding
except it's a horse not a bull and uh
but yeah I got started young and got on
my first bull whenever I was was like 10
or 12 oh my God you know and
uh and then it was all down here from
there I not I mean I had a little bit of
fear involved but I just knew that was
the path I was going on no matter what
and my dad didn't push me you know but
he that's just that was in our blood
that's just what we did and I was going
to do it whether he pushed me or not and
uh and then I just once it got once that
fight experiencing that fight of every
night I I wasn't much for the partying
there's there's a lot of guys that all
of it together the partying and that
lifestyle like I enjoyed having a good
time but for me being behind the shoots
getting ready for that fight that was
what kept me coming back I would imagine
very few people party as hard as Rodeo
guys I would I would agree with
that